I read this story about a bridezilla who
was demanding to get the password to an
email address that she had put on her
wedding invitations for RSVPs without
even grabbing the email address first
does that make sense
oh yeah so she just invented this one
that she didn't even know that it belong
or she couldn't get it she did realize
is she dumb yeah sounds like it
wait she's she wants his email address
because it's it's to her theme or some
[ __ ] well the name is her first name and
her new last which is another human
being who exactly so it turns out to be
this one particular person's email
address of that she's like Rachel Winger
sumption she goes that's my new name and
she already gave it out exactly get out
no waiting in line so she needs the
password so she can get the information
people have been using it this woman
like 80 years old it shows she's not
persons getting flooded with RSVPs and
Rachel wings like I never even said a
wedding up what the [ __ ] well the thing
is like it's really coincidental because
she the the original email a dress owner
is engaged she is planning a wedding
well she started getting RSVPs [ __ ] she
was like what like how are these odd
they're like what so not as no other
chances she's like he has a big family
[ __ ]
honey did you invite a job Ronson like
is this person this is why your [ __ ]
mom yeah but yeah so this person starts
talking about how they all of a sudden
start getting these RSVPs and they're
just very confused so they didn't
recognize the sender's email or any of
the guests that started sending RSVPs so
then that's when mad your password [ __ ]
well initially she responds to the first
RSVP as like you might want to double
check resent this so your arse be
because RSVP goes to the right place so
then her and her fiance were like oh
that's weird
anyway resuming because she's had this
email address since 2005 so then she
started getting to more RSVPs from
different address
so that she was like like they were like
no we double-checked this is the correct
email that's on the RSVP so that's when
she started getting an email from D like
the bride and that that's when this
person started saying like yeah I demand
that you give me your ID em man yeah
because it's like cuz she's the only
[ __ ] with that name that's so funny
the actual reddit post says I replied to
that no oh wait sorry
before that when I get home I got
another RSVP spike making as well as an
email from someone with the same name as
me saying that she's going to need to
that she's going to need me to give her
my email accounts I replied to that as
no and also why she get to the email
back in ten minutes she says that she
got the first the same first name and
that the guy that she's marrying to is
her last name
so that's why she ended up picking that
for the RSVPs so then she ends up saying
like well you're gonna have to pick a
new account this is mine is my full name
I've had it for a literal decade and but
she was trying to be really apologetic
and trying to be nice still so she was
like well you know I I congratulate you
I'm also getting married myself
what if they share it they can share the
email and they could tag-team looking at
all the emails you take it Tuesdays and
Thursdays and Fridays I promise not to
look at each other stuff yeah she says
oh she loses it I get a nasty messy
string of emails from her saying that I
have no right to use her name and what
her fiance is named the same as my last
name why yeah and that she's like her
idiot she was like uh you won't even
need it after you're married so what's
wrong with that like what's wrong with
giving up this email a little early and
that she's ruining her life and her
wedding oh [ __ ] off
it's just go giving [ __ ] narcissistic
exactly a whole bunch of insults and
slurs and saying that learners how did
you know what race she will baby not
reason your email read [ __ ]
face gender-based insulting slurs and
she says she says that she hopes that
her fiance cheats on oh my god she
deserves it and then finally she gave
her one more chance you know or else
what before she's please Oh forth for
theft and that she would owe her a lot
of mom like god I love this how would
she I would want to see her in court I
would want to see you in court
yeah I'm petty I want to see her in
court I want to I don't understand why
can I have my own future name you're not
gonna need it anyway she's like honey
can you believe this [ __ ] we're gonna
take her to court and win and this guy's
just like in the corner like I'm just
trying to get away and the guy's like
can you just pick the color of the
sheets for the wedding already please
I'll be done with this what if it's like
opening a window climbing you get the
name is so basic to like Rachel Johnson
or some [ __ ] where it's like thousands
of people have the same [ __ ] name you
idiot and like what the [ __ ]
senator sent a text message to your
friends you know I'm like no one even
does the RSVP [ __ ] anyways until like
you remind them hey guys can you RSVP
because like I need to have your names
you know and saying this is a chick that
you RSVP and she comes after you for not
showing up to the wedding cuz your wife
was pregnant and giving birth and she
[ __ ] Sue's you for like four grand
for emotional damages this is that
person so then she says that she finally
replied to her tirade telling her under
no circumstances would I be giving
through my email legally she doesn't
have a leg to stand on she's being super
rude why does she their response but
whaling to still like forward the RSVPs
to her
I would have deleted all of our ladies I
would have sent them porn
yep what kind of petty [ __ ] is this it's
not petty why is she still so giving as
soon as I got those emails I would have
been like I want to see you pay [ __ ]
money and go to court I want to ruin
their lives it gets better oh it gets
better
okay let's go let's go yeah and she says
I asked how many people she would invite
so I could get an idea how much work I
just volunteered for and then she ends
up saying she sent back a nasty email
full of expletives and
again demanding my password or nothing
well okay then nothing it is she blocked
her email and she replied to the three
RSVPs that she hadn't talked to yet with
the simple I'm sorry you're not invited
to my wedding anymore or until my
wedding and then she said this has the
benefit of being 100% true albeit
deceptive so then she got another RSVP
and they got a nice skirt not invited
reply as well so then she's like I'm
hoping she has a very large wedding
party but none of them have responded
yet
but if they do respond she plans on
forwarding the email chain between her
her and bridezilla to the guest so
that's where it so it was literally only
three people and she's tripping because
like it's not large three responsive
yeah new RSVP so it's total like five or
something I mean they can't trickle in
yeah but the funny thing is most people
don't even want to [ __ ] gulp why it's
like they're like ah [ __ ] I don't even
that's it it's six wedding right what a
girl girl go yeah this person sounds
like a headache to be with ya how do you
be with someone like that that's so dumb
that like why wouldn't you check the
email isn't like the first thing you
would do you know I'm saying if this
person just like got problems yeah she's
point so [ __ ] hot dog doesn't matter
maybe this is like the type of person
that'll give you a phone number that
they don't even have but the phone
number was their favorite numbers and
then they call the [ __ ] with the
phone number like I should have it those
are my so little spoiled brat she
probably comes from money she used to
getting what she wants
or maybe she's a broke-ass [ __ ] trying
to compensate
[Music]
[Laughter]
this also reminds me of the back when
the internet first camera there's always
people buying all the domain names yeah
just for things in the future and then
they try to sell it back because that's
what happened to I think was it Jessica
in film calm or.net or something and
then they're trying to offer us
something that was like ten times more
than I could even pay for I don't like
$20,000 or some [ __ ] yes some somebody
goes on you owned my Timothy DeLaGhetto
calm way back and then he hit me up on
MySpace and was like hey man just so you
don't buy it off me what not more a
purse he was like hey I actually you
know I do web design I'm down to work
with you and like help you design your
website look at sure and then and then
we did a website for a while and after a
while hey man can I just let me buy it
off you and he gave me some crazy offer
I was like I don't even want this [ __ ]
rolling who cares at the end of the day
but yeah those people like that aren't
they paying monthly or you very don't
mean like spending a ton of like 10
bucks you know but if you buy a whole
bunch that builds up so do you guys
remember when we were super young if you
went to White House calm it was a porn
website no oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so I
remember being like I don't know man in
second grade first grade and kids being
like oh if you go to White House or
maybe not that young but whenever we had
access to like computers yeah they're
like go to White House calm and then it
was like pictures of naked women and
[ __ ] the internet history and she's like
he's learning about government yeah Wow
look at my boy remember calling 1-800 f
uck USA it'd be like some phone sex
operator chick and then they'd be like
for the real whatever call one 900 I'm a
few numbers like that yeah did you do
those yeah oh my god that's crazy
that was boza I think after after my
time of or maybe before month it was
just wasn't my time you never got to
talk to a sexy chick who sounds like
she's out of breath it was always like
people that like no no I remember the
older kids doing that [ __ ] they would
you would call in and then people would
reply to your little voice no it's just
depending on if they want to talk to you
or not so the older like teenagers I
would hang out with like this girl she's
like hey
slap you know what's mean I just
challenge like drop me a message if you
want to talk or something and then she
would hit Little Miss play I agree you
sound cute what do I know we just like a
little like voice no back and forth no
the ones that I used to call in was like
in actually like a chatroom but
everyone's like party like oh yeah yeah
it was kind of when 3-way first came out
as like free service you remember though
I thought that was you like hold on I'm
at and then you add all your friends and
everyone's on the [ __ ] 8 people yeah
yeah well you trick people and have one
person on three-way and see if they were
talking [ __ ] are you phone sex and then
your chicks like yeah I'm getting you
hot you know yeah yeah you giving me hot
like check this up
I mean what was that nice but did I put
it on the phone yeah is it yeah yeah
yeah like five babies like that sounds
big hit a lot of numbers there that was
the best days ever
[ __ ] man that was like social media
dating before social media man everyone
had that what are you doing man what are
you doing like this special voice yeah
the special voice the guys try to sound
or the girls satisfy like you know
whatever bro if I ever call the girl's
house back then I would always like I
would always make sure all super
comfortable so I could like have super
relaxed voice I think lay off and some
pillows and [ __ ] and then I would always
make sure like cuz you know no one had
cell phones you have to talk to the
parents first I've like oh hello is um
can I speak to jail please or whatever
and then but are you sure honey hold on
this one can visit it but that's and
then as soon as the girl gets phone like
yo let's go yo watch every some hot
coffee to relax your face and then you
bring her home to mom and then you like
hittin it in and she's like who the [ __ ]
is this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]